Keamy gah tubby Matsuyama itsumo to
onaji janitor welcome to another episode
of cooking with david machine I love
fusion food meaning I love it when two
things come together to make something
amazing
much like the basketball player Derrick
Rose Vince the cameraman half German
half Japanese Axis powers so today we
are going to cook one of my favorite
fusion dishes we're going to eat Kylie I
see but the bat the boopie another
Japanese so what are we making today my
friends we are making Oni pasta all it
takes really is three eggs and two cups
of flour and that's enough pasta to feed
like I don't know four or five people
first you are going to need a food
processor yes if you don't have a food
processor it's pretty [ __ ] difficult
you got to lay a mound of flour get the
eggs and do it yourself I ain't trying
to do that
this [ __ ] takes it to like 30
seconds pop the lid off boom here it
goes
get your flour if you don't have flour
in your house you should have it because
trust me you will need it a lot when you
cook you be [ __ ] surprised two cups
of flour and it goes get your little
puppy here one egg in two eggs three
eggs
heat it up a little bit get Donita beat
the [ __ ] out of it like a misbehaving
asian child just need to beat it a
little bit just enough so it'll get
straight ace let's add the three eggs to
it right there
let's put the lid on top and here you go
now what you're going to look for when
you see this is that it comes together
and the moment it comes together and it
pulls away from the sides you're
basically good to go here we go hit it
[Music]
did I [ __ ] up the ratio we're gonna add
another egg please let this be right let
it go
[Music]
and there you have it my friends you
don't have any of those weird little
crumblies it pulls away like so but it's
not too wet now at this point this is
what your dough is gonna look like it's
gonna be really tacky and sticky flour
your board just a little bit you don't
need to flower it too much and you're
just going to knead it for about a
minute or so we're not gonna go too long
you're gonna be gentle with it that's
not really just knead it enough where it
comes together and the dough is smooth
you don't want to work up too much of
the gluten strands because if you do
your pastas going to be tough they may
no matter you have it after you knead it
for about a minute this is what you
should have wrap it up and let it rest
for about 15 minutes minimum you want
all that gluten that you activated in it
by doing the little wushu [ __ ] to relax
so you don't have tough pasta and all
that other [ __ ] I actually don't
know the science behind it but that's
what was told to me I love pasta pastas
like one of those dishes that you make
that if you have a girl that you're
dating they get impressed by I don't
know why but for some reason when you
tell them ooh baby I'm gonna be making
pasta they go oh my god let's hope that
50 minutes later our pasta has rested
and now it's time to roll this [ __ ] now
dust your surface lightly and we are
going to take your lovely pasta dough
boom right there let's cut this [ __ ]
into fourths move these aside if you
don't have a rolling pin at home that's
completely okay I don't even use a
rolling pin because we've just started
this cooking show and I haven't made
[ __ ] from it all you really need my
friends is a nice what's that called
tubular cylindrical surface such as this
bottle of olive oil does this look like
I'm doing something else
take your do however July and then we're
just gonna start to roll it and you want
it to be as thin as possible
we're doing the rustic style handmade
pastas so if it's not pretty if it's not
as thin as you see it in those fancy ass
restaurants [ __ ] them they're not doing
it like this like we are they don't know
our struggles this dish is called
struggle pasta it's getting there it's
getting there
if you have a couple of uneven parts I'm
not gonna say it's okay as and that's
what should happen but don't beat
yourself up on it man you're doing it
with the [ __ ] olive oil bottle for
crying out loud
uh this is good enough for me and we are
going to roll this [ __ ] Oh
actually hmm how should I do this yeah
we are going to roll this mother no roll
it up like so we get my knife and then
I'm going to start cutting some strips
of this pasta thick or as thin as you
want just make sure there's even as
possible because you'll want them to
cook evenly
even this ugly little [ __ ] right here I
like them and there you have it fresh
pasta
ready to cook and serve that only took
about 30 minutes and half of that time
my friends was just it resting and doing
nothing much like myself remember we
didn't put any salt into the pasta so
what you're going to do is actually salt
your pasta water now what are you
thinking right now
how salty do you want it to be like the
ocean get yourself a bowl you aren't
going to get yourself a nice fat stick
of butter like so and to that butter may
I say you aren't going to get a fork a
nice big fork and you are going to get
some Unni and what we're doing with this
you asked we are making uni butter and
this is going to be the important part
this is going to be the thing that's
gonna be like whoa bro what did you what
did you what did you do how did you how
did you how did you flavor
here it is there it goes it's getting to
know each other once again if you have a
food processor most likely it's gonna be
a lot creamier than this I don't got
time for that [ __ ] so I'm gonna
leave it there like that
get a nice pen hot and ready because
cooking this pasta is gonna be extra
quick let's take this pasta and then
oops oh [ __ ]
throw it in like so after that water is
boiling we are then going to add chicken
stock just a little to this we are going
to add a little cream to that my friends
we are going to get that cooked pasta
that cooked almost instant taste and
look at that look how big it is look how
awesome it is and add it to this pot
right here a little bit of that pasta
water being added to it is Oh [ __ ] Kay
don't worry I see this liquid is getting
to know each other at this point we are
gonna add a little cracked black pepper
we are going to take that uni butter
stick it in right there it's a lot of
butter I know but that butter is going
to emulsify with the liquid in there
and we are going to get a delicious
velvety creamy uni butter sauce what you
can do if you're looking for more unique
flavor you are going to take this bad
boy right here get yourself up and add a
few more pieces of uni to unify it up
delicious sauce yes yes get yourself a
nice plate like so grab your tongs grab
the pasta
try to place it as pretty as possible
get all those delicious chunks and those
delicious uni pieces right in there get
a few strips of nori take your salmon
roe a nice healthy spoonful of that put
it on top and there you go my friends
Unni pasta simple impressive if you like
the taste of the ocean this is the dish
for you oh and if you really like your
guests before you even do that take some
of those Unni pieces put it on top add a
little fresh uni on there huh
do that there I'm gonna try this out
because I cannot wait
[Music]
that's what's up mix in some of that row
like so take that delicious Unni piece
get it like that
[ __ ] but this is what I'm talking about
ma'am fresh chilli al dente pasta oceany
salty almost like liver of the sea life
Unni
with those salty poppin salmon Rose get
a fat bite like this again
[ __ ] delicious well there you have it
that is the uni pasta or my version of
it give it to your friends impress them
show them what's up and show them that
you can cook might get you later yeah
probably not
breasts pick do you smell that
do you smell the ocean does it smell
like seafood and Poseidon's butthole
getting hungry aren't you a hundred
percent sexy and on a Honda but the hey
I say we didn't have two things coming
together if we had segregation now we
wouldn't have him we would have had the
rock Samoan fragrant fragrant [ __ ] the
stove is a weak-ass [ __ ] how did you
flavor so well I've never heard that
before Melissa take this pasta and then
oops
oh [ __ ] just beeping all over the place